professor kahneman sie sind
nobelpreisträger sie erforschen das
verhalten von uns menschen unter
bedingungen der unsicherheit wenn sie
heute auf diese komplexe welt blicken
was beschäftigt sie am meisten los wird
ich weiß nicht wie wir verändern sich
schneller als früher was mich am meisten
beunruhigt ist nicht die komplexität der
welt
es ist vielmehr die tatsache dass die
jüngere generation heute weniger
hoffnung hat als unsere generation
früher hatte ich habe den zweiten
weltkrieg überlebt aber ich wuchs in
einer welt auf in der man daran glaubte
dass die dinge besser werden
dieses gefühl habe ich heute nicht mehr
sie sprechen ja sehr oft über optimisten
und pessimisten sind die menschen heute
weniger optimistisch wollen sie das
damit sagt ja eindeutig wir waren
überzeugt dass die dinge morgen besser
sein würden
wir hatten zwar große angst vor einem
atomkrieg aber wir waren überzeugt wenn
es nicht zum atomkrieg kommen wird dann
werden die dinge besser
ich glaube unsere kinder und grosskinder
haben dieses vertrauen nicht mehr ein
individuum kann das ändern
als individuen müssen wir es akzeptieren
und uns damit auseinandersetzen aber
dieses gefühl ist verbreitet zumindest
im westen
in china ist die stimmung völlig anders
aber im westen spüre ich dass überall
haben sie denn das gefühl dass diese
einschätzung die hoffnungslosigkeit
realistisch ist
hoffnungslosigkeit ist ein zu starkes
wort
die fehlende hoffnung und
hoffnungslosigkeit ist nicht dasselbe
meine wahrnehmung ist dass die vision
einer besseren zukunft fehlt das scheint
leider realistisch zu sein ist dass auf
ihre persönliche sicht auf die zukunft
vorweg ja ich denke pessimismus ist ein
charakterzug ich bin pessimist und in
stamme einer langen armen linie von
pessimisten auch meine mutter war
pessimisten das hat mich geprägt aber
ich denke heutzutage bin ich nicht der
einzige pessimist ich sehe viel
pessimismus um mich herum
ja genau ich wäre lieber von optimisten
umgeben aber ich sehe verwandte
pessimisten
ich hatte bereits erwähnt dass die
nobelpreisträger sind sie haben 2002 den
nobelpreis für ökonomie erhalten
allerdings als psychologe und als
einziger psychologe mit einem nobelpreis
für ökonomie wie passt das zusammen
ökonomie ist eine disziplin welche die
finanzmärkte analysiert classic in der
klassischen ökonomie versucht man das
marktverhalten von menschengruppen
vorherzusehen
man stellt vermutungen auf wie sich
individuen verhalten und welche
entscheidungen sie treffen börse samt
aus diesen annahmen schließt die
klassische ökonomie dass menschen
rational und egoistisch sind und ihre
vorlieben nicht ändern
psychologen sehen das natürlich völlig
anders
seit ein paar jahrzehnten gibt es einen
austausch zwischen den beiden
disziplinen mehr ökonomen sind bereit
unterschiedlicher annahmen über die
menschliche natur in betracht zu ziehen
samsung baut human human nature hatten
sie bei ihrer forschung immer schon die
ökonomie auge war es bares für sie ganz
wichtig dass es daraufhin zieht oder hat
sich das ergeben
es war ein zufall wir waren psychologen
wir das heißt mein verstorbener kollege
112 ski und ich begannen zusammen unsere
theorie zu entwickeln wir waren
psychologen und betrieben psychologische
forsch angegangen sich einige ökonomen
für unsere forschung zu interessieren
macheten und viel später hatte der
inzwischen pensionierte präsident der
red stage foundation die in den usa sehr
wichtig ist die idee die ökonomie und
die psychologie zusammenzubringen
ich erinnere mich wie er uns an einer
konferenz fragte wie soll ich das an und
ich weiß noch was ich ihm antwortete
gibt keinen psychologen der die
wirtschaft beeinflussen will geld das
ist verschwendung befinden sich jedoch
ökonomen die sich für psychologie
interessieren gib ihnen geld und das hat
er in das erste stipendium der rag
stiftung in gegen richard taylor
er ist mein bester noch lebender freund
er ist ökonom ein guru der
verhaltensökonomie und was interessant
ist für den dialog zwischen den beiden
disziplinen
er wird der nächste präsident der
american economic association 1979
konnte man nur davon träumen dass jemand
der von der psychologie beeinflusst war
präsident der american economic
association werden könnte aber das wird
nun geschehen die beiden also die
disziplin die diese beiden disziplinen
verbindet heißt ja verhaltensökonomik
was will diese forschung genau erkennen
was die verhaltensökonomie anstrebt ich
bin kein öko ich sollte also diese frage
eigentlich gar nicht beantworten
momentan gibt es bereiche in denen die
verhaltensökonomie sehr erfolgreich ist
zuerst einmal in der finanzwirtschaft
es ist erwiesen dass man dort mit
verhaltensforschung viel erreicht ein
wichtiges feld ist auch die politik und
die beziehung zwischen der regierung und
den bürgern anzunehmen dass bürger nicht
so rational handeln wie es die
klassische ökonomie voraussetzt kann
sehr hilfreich sein
das wird in vielen ländern
berücksichtigt meistens geht es dabei
mehr um sozialpsychologie als um
ökonomie eigentlich ist es eine mischung
beider disziplinen und sie gewinnt immer
mehr an einfluss
auch in vielen anderen bereichen werden
verhaltens analysen gemacht zb in der
disziplin recht und ökonomie
es gibt nun auch das fach verhaltens
recht in der ökonomie um realistische
psychologie in die analyse rechtliche
auswirkungen von wirtschafts situationen
einzubeziehen sind sie eigentlich
glücklich damit dass dieses diese
disziplin jetzt den zusatz ökonomie
trägt und ich psychologie es geht nicht
weg von ihrem fach
nein das stimmt nicht ein teil bewegt
sich weg von meinem fach
das ist eine ironie und ich werde gleich
sagen warum aber im allgemeinen hat sich
die ökonomie der psychologie stark
angenähert so sehr dass ein
verhaltensökonom präsidente american
economic association wird etwas das vor
25 jahren undenkbar gewesen wäre und
heute akzeptiert wird
in anderen bereichen beispielsweise in
der politik greifen ökonomen auf die
psychologie zurück und betreiben
eigentlich sozialpsychologie sie
versuchen herauszufinden wie man
menschen dazu bringt mehr zu sparen oder
bereit heiliger steuern zu bezahlen das
sind eigentlich sozialpsychologische
probleme und doch aus irgendwelchen
gründen nennt man das heute
verhaltensökonomie sie sagen sehr
bescheiden sie sind nicht ökonom
sie sagen umgekehrt aber die ökonomen
treiben heute psychologie
trauen sie denn das den ökonomen zu ich
finde sie machen das sehr gut denn sie
sind wirtschaftsexperten das ist
nützlich
dadurch wissen sie wie wichtig
psychologische überlegungen in der
wirtschaft sind wie sich zeigt sind
verhaltensökonomen sehr gute
wissenschaftler und wenn brilliante
leute dinge in gang setzen passiert
etwas
ich bin also sehr optimistisch obwohl
ich pessimistisch
ich vertraue darauf dass in den nächsten
zehn bis 15 jahren in der
verhaltensökonomie interessante dinge
passieren werden ganz einfach weil viele
sehr gute studenten an sehr guten
universitäten dieses fach belegen
dazu gehören zürich harvard berkeley das
ist ein weites entwicklungsfeld sie sind
ja in israel geboren haben dort studiert
sie waren später an fast allen großen
klingenden amerikanischen universitäten
sie haben heute beide
staatsbürgerschaften
sie haben psychologie gewählt hat
dass irgendeine biografische gewand ist
warum sie sich für das innere
funktionierendes menschen interessiert
haben
ich bin in israel geboren aber während
eines besuchs eigentlich fügt sich in
frankreich auf und war auch im zweiten
weltkrieg dort natürlich bin ich jude
und teile die jüdische erfahrung wenn
auch nur teilweise das schlimmste blieb
mir erspart andere haben nicht überlebt
wenn man einen nobelpreis bekommt muss
man eine autobiografie schreiben
aus diesem anlass habe ich über die
vergangenheit nachgedacht
ich habe mich auch gefragt warum ich
psychologe geworden sicher beeinflusste
mich worüber man in meiner familie
sprache ich erinnerte mich dass meine
welt aus menschen und wörtern bestand in
meiner welt gab es sehr wenig natur
wir lebten völlig urban ich habe vor
nichts über blumen und tiere aber wir
sprachen viel über menschen und ich fand
menschen sehr interessant und sie sind
dabei geblieben
schauen wir doch uns ihre forschung
genauer an sie haben eigentlich alles
was sie erforscht haben in diesen doch
relativ dicken buch schnelles denken
langsames denken finken vossloh
veröffentlicht sie haben auch lange
daran gearbeitet das buch wurde ein
internationaler bestseller
warum glauben sie dass leute nach diesem
mittel greifen
was erhoffen sich die menschen davon das
hat mich sehr überrascht ich hätte nicht
erwartet dass das buch so erfolgreich
sein würde denn es ist nicht leicht
verständlich ich dachte es würde schnell
vergessen sie es kam also viel besser an
als ich gedacht hätte wahrscheinlich
weil alle sich dafür interessieren wie
der verstand funktioniert einerseits
können sich die leute darin erkennen und
gleichzeitig staunen sie darüber was die
psychologie alles herausgefunden
das buch handelt nicht von meiner
forschung
ich habe über andere dinge geschrieben
die mich interessieren
ich wollte die psychologie darstellen
wie sie sich heute präsentiert
ich finde die psychologie hat etwas über
das gehirn gelernt und sie hat eine
geschichte welche die leute interessant
finden bevor im industrie in den letzten
jahren sind tausende bücher über
psychologie erschienen und viele zeigen
überraschende fakten auf aber sie
erzählen keine umfassendere geschichte
genau das versuchte ich zu tun
dabei zählte ich die fehler auf die
begangen wurden aber auch die
wunderbaren dinge die wir der intuition
verdanken
eine der haupt geschichten die sie
erzählen beziehungsweise sie geben diese
richtig geschichte ja auch zwei figuren
sind unsere zwei denksystem das system 1
das rasch und spontan funktioniert das
system zwei das kontrollierend eingreift
was muss man sich darunter genauer
vorstellen
ich erkläre die beiden systeme anhand
von zwei sehr einfachen beispiel wenn
ich zwei plus zwei sage geschieht etwas
in ihrem gehirn wenn ich sage die
russische hauptstadt geschieht etwas in
ihrem gehirn wenn ich sage die beziehung
zwischen china und japan kommt ihnen
auch etwas in den sinn nicht ein
einzelnes wort oder eine einzelne idee
in ihrer erinnerung wird vielmehr ein
ganzer themenbereich aktiviert und das
passiert automatisch oder wirtshaus
automatically wenn ich mutter sah
gemacht dass etwas mit ihnen denn sie
denken an ihre mutter und das weckt
gefühle in ihnen auch das passiert
automatisch und das nenne ich system
eins nun zur system 2 sagen wir ich
stelle ihnen eine rechenaufgabe zum
beispiel 17 mal 24 um das auszurechnen
muss ihr gehirn arbeiten
system 2 wird also durch anstrengung
definiert man muss überlegen sich
konzentrieren
das geschieht nicht automatisch
normalerweise haben wir den eindruck
dass wir etwas leisten
ich fühle mich als urheber meines
handelns es ist nicht etwas das mit mir
geschieht sondern etwas das ich tue es
geht um eine denkleistung und um
selbstkontrolle auch wenn ich mich über
jemanden ärgere es aber sich zeigen will
ist system 2 in aktion automat
anstrengung auf der einen seite
automatismen auf der anderen
das buch befasst sich mit dem
wechselspiel zwischen diesen beiden
arten zu denken und zu fühlen
zwischen diesen beiden mentalen
aktivitäten ich spreche ja sehr oft von
denkfaulheit etwas was einen schon
beschäftigt wenn man das buch liest dass
man immer wieder mit der eigenen
denkfaulheit konfrontiert wird ist das
uns menschen angeboren neigen wir dazu
gibt es auch menschen die denkmäler sind
und solche die weniger denkfaul sind
also bei denen ihrer sprache system zwei
seltener zum zuge kommt
was ich denke wir alle sind vor
denn wenn man etwas auf zwei arten tun
kann wählen wir automatisch die
einfachste art sofern damit das gleiche
ziel erreicht werden kann
leistung ist anstrengend und wird als
biologische belastung registriert
mentale und körperliche leistung werden
ganz klar als anstrengung empfunden und
jeder will sich weniger anstrengen
diesbezüglich sind wir alle foul
und die einen viel mehr als andere das
manifestiert sich sehr unterschiedlich
es lässt sich schon bei 34 jährigen
kindern beobachten und wenn man sie 30
jahre später wieder trifft zeigt sich
erstaunliches
es gibt einen berühmten test der sicher
auch hier in der schweiz bekannt ist
entwickelt wurde er von psychologen
wollte er lässt kleine kinder wählen sie
können sofort einen lutscher haben oder
deren zwei wenn sie zehn oder 15 minuten
warten können die kinder die sich fürs
warten entscheiden sind 30 jahre später
völlig anders als jene die den einen
lutscher sofort haben wollen
sie machen einen anderen weg sie gehen
einen anderen weg und kommen viel weiter
sie lassen sich weniger häufig scheiden
sie weisen mehr akademische erfolge auf
sie konsumieren weniger drogen all das
konnte beobachtet werden wollte michelle
sagt auch man könne system zwei schulen
es gibt hinweise dass man leute
trainieren kann sich besser unter
kontrolle zu haben
wie in anderen bereichen auch und es
gibt ein paar tricks mit denen man sich
kontrollieren kann
in volta michelles experiment zum
beispiel sitzen die kinder an einem
tisch und sehen nur die beiden lutscher
sonst ist nichts im raum um der
versuchung zu widerstehen schauen die
erfolgreicheren kinder einfach weg sie
entziehen sich sie wissen wie sie sich
beherrschen können wollte michelle sagt
den kindern auch stellt euch die beiden
luther als bild vor
dann wollen sie diese nicht mehr essen
denn ein bild ist man nicht man kann
sich also mit tricks überlisten doch man
kann selbstdisziplin auch trainieren bei
erwachsenen hat man beobachtet wenn sie
diszipliniert sind und etwas
wirklich tun automatisieren sie es und
haben ihr leben besser unter kontrolle
ob sie buch führen über ihre ausgaben
regelmäßig sport treiben oder eine diät
machen selbstkontrolle zu üben scheint
den menschen zu bekommen
übung macht den meister wie man bei uns
so schön sagen sie sprechen ja sehr oft
von nicht nur von denkfaulheit sondern
von denkmälern von entscheidungs fehlern
sie sprechen davon dass wir die und dass
unsere wahrnehmung verzerrt ist sie
sprechen beispielsweise vom timing oder
vom anker effekt was muss ich mir
darunter vorstellen haben sie da ein
beispiel reden wir zuerst über priming
und dann über den anker effekt vorhin
erwähnte ich die beziehung zwischen
china und japan ist wenn ich dabei viele
worte geflüstert hätte hätten sie einige
besser verstanden als andere zum
beispiel das wort insel
denn china und japan verfügen beide über
insel vielleicht hätten sie krieg oder
navy verstanden viele wörter das nenne
ich sie denken an ein bestimmtes thema
und stellen sofort assoziationen her
sie verfügen über innere bilder die sie
abrufen können das ist der priming
effekt und er hat große auswirkungen er
beeinflusst unsere art zu denken
damit komme ich zum anker effekt ihre
anderen frage diesbezüglich gibt es eine
interessante studie aus deutschland die
fritz strack und seine studenten gemacht
haben
ich glaube in würzburg bei dieser studie
geht es um folgen zuerst frage ich sie
kostet ein deutsches auto
durchschnittlich mehr oder weniger als
200.000 schweizer franken
und dann frage ich sie
was ist der durchschnittliche preis
eines deutschen autors andere probanden
frage ich kostet ein deutsches auto
durchschnittlich mehr oder weniger als
15.000 schweizer franken
und dann frage ich sie nach dem
durchschnittlichen preise
die beiden gruppen schätzen nicht den
gleichen durchschnittspreis und zwar
weil etwas ähnliches passiert wenn ich
200.000 210 franken sage denken sie
einen mercedes an teurer autos
wenn ich sie dann nach dem
durchschnittlichen preis frage kommen
ihnen teure autos in den sinn
bin ich aber mit 15.000 schweizer
franken
denken sie ein billiger autos das ist
der anker effekt ich setze ihnen eine
zahl in den kopf und beeinflusse damit
ihr denken also quasi was mir gesagt
wird was mir mitgeteilt wird dass leitet
mein denken
ich frage mich dabei wird das ausgenutzt
wird das ganz bewusst ausgenutzt
auch klar dass wurde und wird ständig
ausgenutzt marketing arbeitet sehr stark
mit dem anker effekt stellt man zum
beispiel verschiedene telefonmodelle vor
und präsentiert darunter ein sehr
luxuriöses teures modell scheinen alle
anderen modelle viel günstiger zu sein
und die leute tendieren dazu das
zweitteuerste modell zu kaufen
solche dinge werden im marketing
angewendet die marktstrategen haben
nicht auf diese entdeckung der
psychologen gewahrt die wussten das
schon längst aber ihr buch wird bestimmt
von diesen leuten gelesen kann man sich
vorstellen wenn sie das so referieren
muss man den eindruck haben dass wir
eine dass ihr eigentlich unsere welt
falsch wahrnehmen dass wir sie falsch
wahrnehmen
und dass wir aufgrund dieser falschen
wahrnehmung falsche entscheide fällen
wenn ich mit essen vor augen halten dass
vor augen halte und trotzdem auf die
gesellschaft auf uns selbst blicke
machen wir den dauernd fehler ist alles
so falsch wie es läuft oder ist das gar
nicht so wichtig diese vielen kleinen
denkfehler die sie alle war sie gefunden
haben
wir machen nicht ständig fehler zuerst
einmal ist die welt sehr unsicher wir
können also etwas nicht allzu schlau es
tun und es hat gute folgen
andererseits können wir die beste
entscheidung fällen und sie hat ein
desaster zufolge in einer unsicheren
welt ist es schwieriger zu sagen das ist
ein fehler und das ist kein fehler
in vielen bereichen stellt uns das vor
große probleme
auch bei vorstandsvergütungen es ist
also schwierig fehler zu erkennen
fragten sie mich nach den auswirkungen
auf die gesellschaft
ich frage mich wenn wir so viele fehler
machen wie sie sie finden warum wir
deshalb einigermaßen gut funktionieren
die meisten dinge die wir tun gelingen
uns sehr gut wir machen nicht ständig
fehler
man muss nur die fortschritte der
menschheit auch auf individueller ebene
gelingt es meist die menschen sind
talentiert was sie tun haben sie gelernt
und sie meistern vieles recht gut nur
gelegentlich unterlaufen ihnen fehler
doch eine wichtige erkenntnis ist meines
erachtens dass die menschen bei großen
dinge nicht unbedingt vernünftiger
entscheiden als bei kleinen sehr
wichtige entscheide werden nicht
vernünftiger angegangen als unwichtige
das ist interessant und das ist der fall
weil dann system zwei zu wenig zum zug
kommt beispielsweise oder weil wir es
nicht zum zug lassen kommen
er ist damit das anders wäre wie soll
ich sagen ich muss etwas ausholen
was gibt den menschen vertrauen in ihr
urteilsvermögen
grundsätzlich sollte selbstvertrauen für
vernünftige menschen eine urteils
grundlage sein um zu ermessen er gut und
überzeugend ihre argumente sind und zur
weiterreise wird in fahrt aber in
wirklichkeit ist vertrauen keine urteils
grundlage sondern eine emotion
eingeführt und das gefühl des vertrauens
entsteht vor allem dadurch dass man sich
eine einfache geschichte über die welt
erzählt eine geschichte die sinn macht
je einfacher die geschichte ist desto
größer ist ihr vertrauen
so funktionieren die dinge tatsächlich
leben wir in einer subjektiven welt die
viel einfacher ist als die reale welt
muss sie erzählen uns geschichten welche
die welt vereinfachen und diese
geschichten beeinflussen große und
kleine entscheidungen und weil vertrauen
ein so mächtiges gefühl ist fällt es
einem schwer sich zu sagen jetzt drossel
ich mal das tempo
egal ob ich vertrauen habe oder nicht
das liegt den meisten nicht im blut
jetzt da sind carla bruni haben sie
deshalb versucht aus ihrer doch
komplexen forschung ein buch zu machen
dass eine geschichte erzählt ein
wirklicher tatsächlich viele geschichten
in meinem buch drin aber die tatsache
dass sie diesen inneren konflikt mit
zwei figuren beschreiben
damit tun sie ja genau das was was sie
sagen so vereinfachen wir unsere welt
wir versuchen sie zu begreifen wie sehr
in simple geschichten packen absolut
also haben sie selber diesen trick auch
angewendet ihm wissen dass es einer ist
klar ich gehe sogar weiter und mache
etwas noch schlimmeres im und das
absichtlich in der psychologie gibt es
eine stillschweigende abmachung nach der
etwas nicht erlaubt nämlich das
verhalten einer person zu erklären indem
man sich kleine personen hancock
vorstellt die ihr verhalten darstellt
seriöse psychologen tun das nicht
ich habe das in meinem buch sehr bewusst
getan denn ich beschreibe system 1 und
system 2 als ob sie darsteller mit einer
eigenen persönlichkeit wären sie
reagieren aufeinander kontrollieren sich
gegenseitig und streiten miteinander
das habe ich absichtlich getan denn es
ist sehr einfach für uns so zu denken
indem wir uns vorstellen wie diese
figuren interagieren können wir komplexe
und subtile prozesse viel besser
verstehen als wenn wir sie anders
erklären
sie gelten als der wichtigste psychologe
der gegenwart ist das unter anderem auch
deshalb weil sie sich über quasi regeln
ihrer disziplin hinweggesetzt haben
was wenn diese ranglisten würde ich
nicht zu ernst nehmen
das werk von mir und es ist für ski
er starb 1996 ich habe ihn überlebt
unser werk war einflussreicher als das
andere psychologen weil wir das denken
erforscht haben
jeder mensch steckt und wir erforschen
das denken an hand von beispielen die
jeder versteht
psychologen die etwas anderes studieren
können solche beispiele nicht verwenden
wir hatten als er das große glück dass
wir uns mit einem problem befassen
konnten dass auch leute verstehen die
nicht vom fach sind
diese chance haben die meisten
psychologen nicht deshalb hat unser werk
außerhalb der psychologie mehr einfluss
gehabt als andere
das ist reines glück dass lok glück ja
ja aber wo es aber auch etwas tun für
skript denke ich das ist schon die
voraussetzung sie haben sie haben das
beschrieben wir schätzen unsere umwelt
möglicherweise falsch ein dass für zu
schwierigen entscheiden
sie haben aber gleichzeitig gesagt dass
es unserer sicht auf die welt
vereinfacht dass wir sozusagen einfach
erleben können damit das ist ja ein
punkt aber trotzdem wenn wir anschauen
wo ihre forschung auswirkungen gehabt
hat und wo sie auch wirklich diskutiert
wird und diskutiert werden muss
dann müssen wir heute auf die
finanzmärkte blicken das ist klar
die trader und börsianer sind ja so eine
wichtige spezies in diesem großen markt
die ständig analysieren und entscheide
fällen die teilweise von sehr grosser
tragweite sind wie würden sie das
psychogramm dieser trader zeichnen
es gibt sehr unterschiedliche typen von
börsianern
ich persönlich habe ihre psyche nicht
erforscht aber ich habe darüber gelesen
professionellen börsenhändler müssen
zuerst einmal optimisten sein
pessimisten während der fehl am platz
viele sind optimisten unter motivation
und emotion wichtige komponenten im
börsenhandel sind brauchen börsianer ein
gutes selbstwertgefühl
ein forscherteam in cambridge versucht
er herauszufinden
die börsenhändler durch testosteron
beeinflusst werden
und man fand heraus dass ihr
testosteronspiegel ansteigt wenn sie
erfolg haben
sie betreiben also nicht nur eine rein
intellektuelle tätigkeit der
börsenhandel ist ein komplizierter
vorgang in dem es um wettbewerb um
gewinnen und verlieren geht und sicher
gibt es noch einiges in der psyche der
trader zu erforschen manche sind
überdies sehr begabt alle haben stärken
in gewissen bereichen und viele sind in
wichtigen bereichen talentiert das geld
in berlin boden tricks sie hatten
testosteron genannt das bringt mich
natürlich zur frage hat dieses verhalten
dieser überschießen der optimismus wie
sie es jetzt implizit auch gesagt haben
hat dieses verhalten auch ein gender
aspekt gibt es da eine offenkundige
differenz zwischen männern und frauen
ich denke tendenziell haben mehr männer
ein übersteigertes selbstbewusstsein als
frauen
das hat zur folge dass unter den
anlegern die ihr eigenes geld
investieren frauen erfolgreicher sind
als männer etwas ganz einfach weil sie
weniger tun
sie verkaufen und kaufen weniger sie
halten aktien
männer sind tendenziell aktiver und
setzen ideen schneller um und die
meisten ideen sind schlecht die weniger
schlechte ideen man als anleger um sitzt
desto besser geht es eine zunehmen
müsste also lieber nichts tun ist besser
als viel falsches tun so ungefähr an der
börse bestimmt einzelinvestoren sollten
den allgemeinen rat der
verhaltensökonomen befolgen haltet euch
von der börse fern
ihr könnt investieren aber dann
beauftragt jemanden der für euch handelt
am besten investiert ihr in indexfonds
die den kursbewegungen des index folgen
aber versucht nicht besonders clever zu
sein und investiert auch nicht in
jemanden der versucht clever zu sein
es ist ja interessant die sagen dass
eigentlich soll man in diesen märkten
mehr den maschinen vertrauen als den den
beratern und das sozusagen und
gleichzeitig sagen sie wir sollten
langsamer denken das heißt mehr
reflektieren mehr darüber nachdenken und
gleichzeitig haben wir in der börse so
etwas wie computer wie maschinen die
diese arbeit noch viel schneller
erledigen
also was ist nun besser das noch
schnellere rechnen beziehungsweise
rechnen lassen oder das langsamere
denken nun langsamer zu denken hilft
ihnen besser über etwas lohnenswertes
nachzudenken
doch wenn man über etwas wenig weiß
bringt das nicht viel wenn es darum geht
auch die richtigen aktien zu setzen kann
man komplizierte überlegungen anstellen
aber eigentlich ist investieren ein
glücksspiel
denn viele tun das gleiche und legen
einen preis fest und wer meint ohne
insider informationen mehr zu wissen
gibt sich in den meisten fällen eine
illusion
was haben sie noch gefragt die der
gegensatz zwischen den beratern und den
computern die handeln die computer sind
ja noch schneller und sie erhöhen das
tempo noch stärker und führen jetzt zum
teil auch zu schwierigen entscheidungen
hätten die margen würden sie die
auffallen behalten wollen oder würden
sie sagen erst recht mehr macht den
computern band dann läuft das rationale
ab das ist eine ernsthafte frage und ich
weiß nicht genug darüber um ihnen eine
intelligente antwort zu geben
aber eines ist klar man muss sich
ernsthaft fragen ob computer im
börsenhandel zu viel macht haben
das ist doch es ist eine andere art von
technischer handel
es geht darum sehr schnell auf kleine
kursschwankungen der aktien reagieren zu
können
das ist etwas völlig anderes als wenn
einzelinvestoren sich entscheiden in
eine firma zu investieren
müsste das company und würden sie denn
die individuen tendenziell lieber
fernhalten wollen
oder würden sie quasi sagen man darf
aktien nicht so schnell wieder verkaufen
man muss sie länger halten um einfach
das tempo rauszunehmen
das würde ich nicht tun
ich weiß zu wenig über die börse um über
börsen regulierung sprechen zu können
dazu kann ich nichts intelligentes sagen
mein rat an einzelinvestoren ist wie
gesagt kauft indexfonds und versucht
nicht clever zu sein
außer man sieht es als unterhaltung denn
es ist wie glücksspiel im casino kann
aber ein teures vergnügen sein
ein thema das uns in der schweiz sehr
beschäftigt unter anderem in austausch
oder in auseinandersetzung um das besser
zu sagen mit den usa ist die
steuerehrlichkeit von leuten die
tatsache dass menschen versuchen ihr
vermögen am fiskus vorbei irgendwo zu
deponieren
was steckt hinter diesen entscheiden und
gibt es etwas aus ihrer theorie wo man
sagen könnte da könnte man eingreifen
ein solches verhalten der wedding der
versuch steuern zu hinterziehen ist
nichts neues in der schweiz
ich denke dieses phänomen gibt es
überall seit steuern erhoben werden
die meisten leute haben den eindruck das
sei ihr geht und man nehme es ihnen weg
in einigen ländern ist das schlimmer als
in anderen
in den usa ist es extrem dort finden
viele das ist mein geld und die
regierung entwendet es mir
steuern werden von manchen leuten fast
als diebstahl bezeichnet als würde die
regierung den leuten ihr geld
es gab versuche ich glaube in
großbritannien mit denen man die leute
dazu bewegen wollte bereit weniger
steuern zu zahlen
mit geringer wirkung aber es sind
interessante versuche zum beispiel
einzelpersonen müssen steuern bezahlen
und es ist wichtig für die regierung
dafür zu sorgen dass sie pünktlich
zahlen das gilt für selbstständig
erwerbende sein in denen drohbriefe zu
schicken und zu schreiben wie
schrecklich es ist wenn sie die steuern
spät zahlen bringt wenig gut
funktioniert hingegen wenn man den
bewohnern sagen wir von edinburgh
schreibt 94 prozent der bevölkerung
zahlen ihre steuern pünktlich das hat
eine wirkung drohungen nutzen am besten
verstärkt mann das bewusstsein einer
sozialen noch
ich empfand die schweiz diesbezüglich
immer als vorbildlich zum beispiel was
die sauberkeit und die wegwerf
mentalität betrifft zu wissen dass
niemand dinge wegwirft ist eine starke
motivation nicht wegzuwerfen bosna
toilette muss soll ideal ist nicht mehr
überall in der schweiz aber ich weiß was
sie meinen es ist schon so dass bei uns
die das gefühl dass der staat das geld
einfach stiehlt ist bei uns sicher
weniger ausgeprägt weil wir selber
darüber bestimmen können wie hohe
steuern bezahlen wollen das ist schon
etwas anders ausgeprägt da sind wir
eigentlich jetzt fast schon in der
politik und das ist ein weiteres feld
das nicht sehr interessiert sie haben
das auch am anfang erwähnt dass ihre
forschung ja in der politik auch einen
großen einfluss hat wenn wir den schritt
jetzt machen von der finanzkrise in die
staatsschuldenkrise wo wir uns heute
befinden kämpfen ja sehr viele
industriestaaten damit
dass ihre schulden ihres ihre haushalte
überschuldet sind und das wiederum wirkt
sich stark aufbaus beispielsweise auf
die zukünftige finanzierung der
altersvorsorge
jetzt ist es ja so dass wir länger leben
und das müsste eigentlich allen menschen
einleuchten dass wenn wir länger leben
dass wir entweder länger arbeiten oder
mehr sparen fürs alter
aber offensichtlich ist das politisch
fast nicht durchzubringen woran liegt
das
nun auch das ist nicht mein
spezialgebiet
ich antworte also einfach als alter mann
und nicht als fachperson sicher hat sich
in meiner lebenszeit das konzept von
recht und anspruch entwickelt welche
rechte gesteht man den menschen zu und
vor welchen schicksalsschlägen müssen
sie geschützt werden
in europa wird beispielsweise den
menschen das recht zugestanden dass sie
vor krankheit geschützt werden
das ist ein recht ein anspruch sie haben
ein anrecht auf medizinische betreuung
in den usa ist das nicht so eindeutig
wenn auch heute mehr us bürger dafür
sind kürzlich gab es wieder einen
rückschlag
aber viele menschen haben inzwischen
mehr rechte und ein würdevoller
ruhestand wird heute als recht
betrachtet und plötzlich oder vielmehr
nach und nach über die letzten jahre
wurde uns dieses recht wieder
weggenommen oder geschmälert
das können die leute schwer akzeptieren
was nicht erstaunlich ist so groß und es
ist ja vielleicht noch nicht mal so dass
das recht schon genommen wird sondern es
wird nur gedroht
das recht zu nehmen oder zu vermindern
die verpflichtungen runterzufahren und
sie sagen ja in ihrer theorie dass der
angst dass die angst vor dem verlust
viel größer ist als der mögliche
entgangene gewinn musste man das kann
man das in
diesem thema den leuten erklären und
sagen ihr gewinnt dafür mehr sicherheit
im alter wenn je länger arbeitet ist das
würden die menschen darauf anders
reagieren ganz bestimmt zuerst einmal
ist es logisch dass die leute sich gegen
jede reform wäre reformen funktionieren
meistens weniger gut als erwartet und
zwar weil jede reform gewinner und
verlierer produziert wobei die
potenziellen verlierer einer reform viel
stärker bekämpfen als die potenziellen
gewinner voll
das hat einen großen einfluss darauf wie
sich die dinge entwickeln
es gibt daher bestrebungen sachverhalte
anders zu präsentieren
vorgestern las ich in einem artikel den
mir jemand geschickt hatte es ist
einfach verluste wahrzunehmen
aber wenn leute etwas als verlust
empfinden ist es viel schwieriger sie
davon zu überzeugen diese als gewinn zu
sehen
wenn also leute angst haben etwas zu
verlieren ist es schwierig sie vom
gegenteil zu überzeugen das ist ein dort
das größere problem zeigt sich zwischen
den generationen leute die heute
pensioniert werden finden die rente
stehen ihnen zu
das anrecht auf ihre rente habe man
ihnen versprochen
es gibt also viele gründe für diese
verlust aversion die manche leute haben
doch früher oder später werden wir
länger arbeiten müssen
das scheint unvermeidbar und ist wohl
eine gute sache
das liegt ja auch eigentlich auf der
hand wenn wir uns selbst fragen
wenn ich etwas 17 das merkt man auch bei
kindern wenn man ihnen etwas wegnimmt
ist das viel schlimmer als wenn sie es
noch gar nicht haben also offenbar
ticken wir so und sie haben das auch
deutlich heraus gefunden gibt es ja ein
anderes interessantes
totaler und sonst ein taler hatten sie
bereits erwähnt auf deutsch der anstoß
also dass man menschen durch die
richtige frage stellung dazu anstößt die
richtige entscheidung zu fällen
ein beispiel das immer wieder genannt
wird ist die organspende
das thema wurde in dieser sendung
kürzlich auch behandelt wie kann man
mehr menschen dazu bringen ihr organ zu
spenden nicht indem man sie fragt wollen
sie ihr organ spenden sondern indem man
sagt eigentlich spenden alle menschen
ihre organe außer jemand setzt sich hin
und schreibt ich will mein organ nicht
spenden
und dieses prinzip wird von den beiden
autoren liebert ära paternalismus
genannt und da sie schon einen gewissen
gegensatz wie viel freiheit lässt man
denn den menschen noch wenn man
eigentlich ihre entscheidung schon vor
spurt vor allem hat man herausgefunden
wie sehr man das verhalten von leuten
mit dem vorgeben von standard antworten
beeinflussen kannst du affe im sinn von
wenn sie nichts tun passiert das und das
ob sie nun ankreuzen müssen dass sie
ihre organe spenden wollen oder
ankreuzen dass sie ihre organe nicht
spenden wollen
sollte sie nicht beeinflussen denn sie
müssen nur ein kreuz machen das ist
keine große sache aber wie sich zeigte
hatte es einen großen einfluss in
europäischen ländern mit
zustimmungsregelung in denen also die
standard antwort lautet ich spende meine
organe ist die spenderquote bei 85 bis
95 prozent in den anderen ländern ist
sie bei 10 bis 20 prozent mit den ost
werden die quoten in deutschland und
österreich weiß ich nicht mehr
interessant ist aber dass im einen land
die widerspruchsregelung und im anderen
die zustimmungsregelung gilt und der
unterschied in der spenderquote ist
gigantisch das ist lieber therapie ihre
vertreter finden zum wohl der
gesellschaft brauchen wir viele organe
also lautet standard antwort ich spende
eine organe
es ist freiwillig wer seine organe nicht
spenden will muss es nicht tun aber weil
system zwei träge ist kreuzen die
meisten leute die standard-antwort an
ähnliche dinge kann man auch beobachten
wenn nicht wie bei der organspende die
gesellschaft sondern das individuum
profitiert das sieht man bei den
betriebsrenten in den usa bei einer
lohnerhöhung steigen die beiträge
automatisch außer der arbeitnehmer
kreuzt an dass er weniger sparen dadurch
lägen die leute viel mehr auf die hohe
kante
nur wenn sie nicht weiter sparen wollen
kreuzen sie das an den manager in den
usa ist dadurch in einigen betrieben die
sparquote von 3 prozent auf 11 prozent
gestiegen nur durch diese standard
antworten
in den usa hat man also die leute nicht
durch ein gesetz sondern durch die
manipulation mittels einer standards
antwort zum sparen bewegt dass dich wort
genannt manipulation das ist das was
nicht beschäftigt weil theorie sagt ja
weil wir das wissen was unter anderem
herausgefunden haben das system zwei
eben träge ist müssen wir system 1
überlisten indem wir eine andere frage
stellen und sie sagen aber gleichzeitig
dieser libertäre paternalismus ist dann
gerechtfertigt wenn er transparent ist
wie reagiere ich denn wenn ich eine
andere frage bekomme und mir
gleichzeitig gesagt wird diese frage ist
deshalb anders weil sich nicht
überlisten bin ich dann nicht wach genug
und zu sagen achtung da versucht jemand
zu überlisten
in der voest in mexiko zuerst einmal
muss man in vielen situationen die dinge
vor spuren großer zeiler und kerstin
machen ihre idee am beispiel einer
cafeteria fest in der speisen
ausgestellt werden
was soll der betreiber seinen gästen auf
augenhöhe präsentieren
gesunde speisen oder solche die
dickmacher er muss sich entscheiden
und warum sollte er seine gäste nicht
dabei unterstützen sich zu kontrollieren
und dinge zu essen die ihnen gut tun
denn eigentlich wollen sie sich gesund
ernähren
aber wenn sie speisen sehen die dick
machen sind sie versucht diese zu wählen
das ist das grundprinzip
man gibt den leuten eine kleine auswahl
in gewissen bereichen wie der
organspende schlagen sonst in unfairer
aber nicht die standard antwort vor
sie zwingen die leute sich zu
entscheiden sie geben zwei antwort zuvor
von denen man eine ankreuzen muss hier
gewichten sie die freiheit stärker als
dem paternalismus in gewissen bereichen
finden die verhaltensökonomen diese
methode besser wenn wir noch einen
moment bei der freiheit bleiben haben
sie auch einen erstaunlichen fund
gemacht befund gemacht sie sagen dass
die menschen eigentlich weniger den
fakten traum die sie lesen können die
sie erfahren können sondern sie glauben
eigentlich primär menschen denen sie
vertrauen
also ich halte mich wenn ich mir eine
meinung bilde eigentlich eher an
personen als an fakten
das bedeutet wenn wir noch mal
zurückkommen zu den politischen reformen
sei es so altersvorsorge oder was auch
immer dass ich menschen vertrauen muss
wenn also das man vertrauenswürdige
personen an der spitze haben muss einmal
reformen durchbringen muss verleitet
einen das nicht dazu zu sagen dass diese
ganze auseinandersetzung mit
führungspersönlichkeiten in der politik
eigentlich viel schwieriger ist dass wir
eigentlich autoritäten haben sollten die
sagen wir können das wir wissen dass wir
machen das jetzt so
das ist sicher nicht mein spezialgebiet
aber ich kann etwas erzählen dass ich
vor zwei wochen in china erlebt habe ich
reiste ferienhalber durch das land und
was einheimische touristenführer dort am
meisten sagen ist regierung eigentlich
hört man vor allem zwei begriffe eltern
und regierung aber dort tut die
regierung viel für die menschen und sie
fällt entscheidungen für sie hier in der
schweiz erleben sie das andere extrem
sie können gegen alles das referendum
ergreifen beide systeme haben vor und
nachteile und sie widerspiegeln auch die
jeweilige kultur des landes leuten die
referenten gewohnt sind die damit
aufgewachsen sind und erlebt haben was
sie bewirken kann man kein autoritäres
regime aufzwingen
einerseits ist es nicht klar wie die
chinesen reagieren würden wenn man sie
von ihrem autoritären system befreien
würde und ihnen absolute freiheit gebe
ich glaube das kann man nicht einfach
beantworten
vielleicht ist das mein pessimismus aber
ich sehe dafür keine einfache antwort
fast schon wieder am anfang und damit
auch bald am schluss ihr pessimismus
sie bezeichnen sich selbst als
defensiven pessimisten
was meinen sie damit ich habe das wort
nicht verstanden was ich gesagt habe ich
habe leider das englische original nicht
aber ich habe gelesen dass sie sich als
defensive nicht abgespeichert
skeptischen aber sieht sie nennen es
defensiven pessimisten bezeichnen
[Gelächter]
daran erinnere ich mich nicht es gibt
den ausdruck defensiven pessimismus
das heißt wenn man mit dem schlimmsten
rechnet ist man immer positiv überrascht
als pessimist habe ich große vorteile
ich bin fast nie enttäuscht
weil ich mit dem schlimmsten rechnen bin
ich recht oft positiv überrascht denn
die welt zeigt sich meistens besser als
ich erwartet habe
das erlebe ich bei kleinen dingen immer
wenn ich meine schlüssel nicht finde
denke ich ich hätte sie verloren und
dann finde ich sie und bin erleichtert
eigentlich ist das sehr denn ich finde
sie fast immer
trotzdem denke ich jedes mal ich hätte
sie verloren wenn sie den pessimismus
doch so nicht hochhalten aber doch
eigentlich für eine realistischere
einschätzung der welt und des geschehens
halten
warum machen sie sich dann sorgen über
die pessimisten darüber dass die leute
zu wenig hoffnungsvoll sind hob ist es
seien schon fängt durch ich denke
hoffnung ist wesentlich für das
menschliche glück und wohlbefinden das
hoffen zu können dass die dinge besser
werden ist sehr wichtig für uns menschen
ohne diese hoffnung fehlt einem etwas im
leben wie groß und umfassend diese
hoffnung sein muss weiß ich nicht aber
wenn menschen den eindruck haben in
einer welt zu leben die schlimmer wird
finde ich das sehr traurig einem
letztlich das system 1 er hilft
optimistisch zu sein als das system 2
tendenziell sind die meisten menschen
optimisten
ich bin meistens optimistisch
das ist ganz natürlich wir machen pläne
wir haben wünsche und verwirkliche sie
die meisten menschen können von dieser
haltung profitieren
interview ob er optimistisch sind oder
nicht wirkt sich auf unsere
lebenseinstellung und weltsicht aus es
beeinflusst unsere art zu leben und die
welt in der wir leben wahrzunehmen mixa
der 52 kapitel lehman habe vier abba the
world
also sind sie am schluss reicht gar
nicht so unglücklich damit das system
zwei nicht immer da ist und dann nur
dann zum zuge kommt wenn es soll und
system 1 eigentlich versagt dann doch
nicht ich habe gehofft wir können
optimistisch schließen aber bleiben wir
dabei bleiben wir ausgewogen und sagen
hab ich bin auch froh wenn wir mit einem
optimistischen gedanken schließen können
dann zeigen wir dabei professor kai
niemann
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch
[Musik]